a marine a u.s marine told me the first
criterion for being a leader is you have
to want to be one
um and if you look at the way the
marines select their leaders select
their officers it's
different than than with their enlisted
corps so if you enlist in the marine
corps
you go to paris island in the east or
you go to
uh san diego and the west to boot camp
and they will make you into a marine
that's what it says we make marines yeah
and uh if you change your mind
you're gonna be in the marine corps
whether you like it or not there is no
change in your mind yeah once you sign
on the dotted line
you're in yeah and the officer corps
it's different if you want to be an
officer in the marine corps you go to
ocs and
quantico virginia um and uh
uh it's a 10-week training and uh
you only have to stay in the first four
weeks uh
for the next six weeks you can drop out
at any time for any reason yeah
um and the reason is is because if you
don't want to be a leader
they don't want you yeah they give you
the choice um
you know leadership to me is like is
like it's like
being a parent everybody has the
capacity to be a parent doesn't mean
everybody wants to be a parent and
everybody should be a parent right
leadership is the same everybody has the
capacity doesn't mean everybody wants it
and doesn't mean everybody should yeah
it comes at great personal sacrifice it
means you have to
constantly worry about other people like
being a parent yeah um
you have to uh love them whether you
chose them or not yeah
you know yeah your team uh
and uh and there are skills to being a
parent and everyone who's ever had a
child
starts reading books when they find out
that they're pregnant for the first time
you know uh they start asking their
friends they start asking their parents
for advice
and it's constant you know whether the
kid's struggling at school or struggling
at home or having a good time there's
it's all the things like i i hate
hanging out with my sister and my
brother-in-law
when they're with their their other
friends who have families because all
they talk about
is kids yeah right um uh well
leadership's the same
yeah leadership's the same you know the
the great leaders that i know are all
students of leadership they're obsessed
they're constantly talking about it
they're reading books about it they're
watching talks about it they're reading
articles about it
they get together they it's it's the
topic of conversation
um and so you know if you want to learn
the skill set
i mean number one you have to want to do
it um and b you're gonna have to do some
work
yeah i mean it takes it takes effort
you